the public
members of the press and the other
members i've forgotten about welcome
along
uh to this meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships committee
um welcome to councillor amanson on zoom
we have an apology from councillor
arnold if somebody would like to move
councillor scout secretary councillor
clark
put that all in favor against
carried which brings us to the report of
the invercargill
uh youth council we've got libby
alexander
and cariana who have come along along
with ollie if you want to take the
graham norton seats up at that table
there and hold on real tight
welcome along uh councillor crackit and
i
uh were both at the the last
meeting for the youth council and
commander you're a particularly engaged
group
and and really nice to to work with
um thanks very much for your report uh
the
there's one of the other items in there
that you were going to speak to was the
poppy flight event which uh i think his
worship was at
last week as well and anything else
you're wanting to enlighten us on the
floor is yours
just remember whoever's having a turn if
you can just make sure that microphone
is in front of you please for those who
are on zoom
kia ora i'm alexander and i'm the deputy
chair of the unders
um i'm katyana and i am the
one of the chairpersons of the unders
hi i'm libby and i'm one of the chief
persons of the overs
so the first thing that the youth
council would like to cover today
is about the waiata and pepeha so
georgia and the corporate planner did a
session with us at the last year council
meeting about
uh pp house and we all went through ours
and learned how to write them and things
like that
and so now we're just working towards
incorporating these into our formal
occasions
so with that we're thinking that at our
youth council meetings we might have
someone
start off off with our combined meetings
by doing their ppcr
and we've also been learning the council
wireta
which is what we use to open our
combined meetings once the unders come
together and we also sang it at the
poppy flight welcome
i'm going along with the poppy flight
uh well once we got there we welcomed
in the knitted artwork that was
traveling around new zealand
fundraising for the rsa and the starship
foundation
um it flew in with the pilot on a tiger
moth
and we welcomed him in with the council
rioter
then maya tim added to this writer with
one of his own
and then we took a photo for the paper
with the artworks
and you can head to our facebook page to
see the photo from the property flight
and also about innovating streets
uh our representatives met with
our coms team and talked about how
innovating streets will work
and we are looking forward to further
discussion on how we
will provide a youth voice on this
kia ora um to start off with i'll talk
about the long-term plan
um some of our members billy and tyler
are going to talk to the schools about
how young people can put a submission in
um other members are attending two of
the engagements
events for the long term plan um
we were lucky enough to be offered a
behind-the-scenes tour last week of the
hydra slide which was really cool
and we're really stoked to be invited to
ride the new hydro slides before the
public
and it is tomorrow evening we look
forward to being involved with the
official opening on the 19th of april
cool thanks guys um we
certainly look forward to hearing your
feedback on
innovating streets i know there's some
new developments coming up there and
and your feedback on that's going to be
really important and
also appreciate you going out and
sharing the word about the long-term
plan
obviously as we we build the city and
plan for it 10 years at least into the
future 30 years for infrastructure
we're building it for you so what you
think is important and if you're able to
encourage
your peers school mates to do the same
that's just wonderful thank you for that
um councillors are there any questions
of the youth council representatives
councillor lewis
thank you chair
i'm really excited about the ability and
and the import of the
youth council these days and catego how
did you enjoy being a member of the
creative community
council committee yesterday
it was a very good meeting very
informative as well
having not been on a committee like that
before and
just observing as well what was how it
worked and what was going on it was very
interesting i'm
very excited for all the further
meetings and we're very pleased to have
you and
now answer it on that committee thank
you very much thank you
it's nice to spend somebody else's money
especially when you see when it's going
to really
good projects it's it's a good thing to
to be involved with thank you councillor
lewis
any other questions from councillors
if not i'm prepared to move that the um
invercargill youth council report is
received there's a second councillor
lewis thank you
i'll put the motion all in favor against
carried thank you very much for coming
along know that you've got to leave
school pretty promptly to get here for
our three o'clock start so we do
appreciate that um
you are welcome to stay and watch how
the rest of the meeting proceeds or
get on with your lives it is up to you
but thank you
thank you
councillors we've got the minutes of the
performance policy and partnerships
meeting
from tuesday 9th of march
uh would somebody like to move that it's
a true and correct record council of
partnership councillor soper looking for
questions comments or feedback
just on my schedule i've got um
an item
to discuss uh
the agenda and i don't seem to have it
listed on my schedule
to to discuss what's your agenda sorry
sit uh there's this one
and it's um
to discuss the agenda and there isn't an
agenda on my
future
probably had to leave it doesn't appear
anywhere
okay thank you for your indulgence thank
you worship
to the march 9th meeting it's been moved
and seconded if no one has
any points to raise or put the motion
all in favor
against carrie thank you for that
uh minutes of the extraordinary
performance policy and partnerships
meeting
on march 29th excuse me councillor
supermoved
councillor skelt seconded
any questions or comments
if none i'll put the motion all in favor
against carried
uh the reports on the proposed
name change in relation to the
subdivision of
sunrise drive mr day has
a report this was originally on the
agenda
uh for the last meeting but there were a
couple of issues around it that we
went back to the developer with
mr day if you'd like to speak to the
report please
cure chair councillor and council and
your worship the report that's presented
before you i'll take is read
we have gone through and discussed with
the
subdivision occupants and also owner
and this report comes back having been
approved by
all those mentioned
thank you so there are two
recommendations there i'm looking at
councillor lewis because i know that you
were having discussions with
a couple of the parties are you happy to
move them absolutely i'd like to move
that
the report was received and the the name
that we choose is option one arcadia
pace
this is in in conjunction with the
quite extensive discussions that went
between the submitter
and the concerned residents in the area
and i'm so pleased that uh consensus has
been
achieved and the residents i think will
be delighted to have their
first choice so thank you to the
submitters and also thank you very much
the
developer for the compromise that he may
have made
thank you for checking that okay as
seconded councillor everett thank you
for that
any other points or comments that anyone
has to make
if not i'll put the motion then all in
favor
against and carried that brings us
to the empirical city council's
enforcement policy
um i think there was
some feedback around around one of the
items however you've had a chance to
have a look
at the report from mr morris are you
going to add into that afterwards darren
or is michael going to
okay thank you michael thank you
council is your worship so this is our
enforcement policy we've um brought it
back for
its adoption and as the chair has
alluded to there is one small
change we're going to make to it it's
been brought to our attention
uh thank you mr mckenzie in relation to
our
missing uh has no so the hazardous
substances
act from uh the enforcement policy
so council does as a territorial
authority have a small
jurisdiction in this area and so it
should rightfully be included
uh so at paragraph two
of the policy where we set out the
various acts that we act under
we're going to add in a small a
paragraph to cover off our
obligations under the hazardous
substances
act
if you would like i can read out the
paragraph
does anybody want the paragraph read
silence random we all got wet good save
i am obliged um and outside of this
we're really looking forward to having
this policy in place it will provide a
great level of guidance to
our compliance teams and we're looking
forward to developing the strategy
underneath it on how we give effect to
it
so i'm more than happy to answer any
questions thank you michael so there are
two recommendations um so the first is
receiving
the report and then adopting the
enforcement policy if we can add
with the suggested change to incorporate
has no obligations is that
sufficient that will be sufficient yes
soon
did i say suggest i'd please take it out
then
councillor sopa happy to move both the
recommendations
mr chair thank you
h h s n o h it's a long time since we
did the district plan
which was the last time i dealt with it
sounds like somebody's sneezing
so moved councillor soap sorry seconded
by councillor abbott wasn't it yep
was it councillor scout my apologies
i'll take guidance was it yes thank you
questions or comments
call put the motion all in favor aye aye
aye against
carrie which
brings us to the quarterly financials
jamie
welcome along
so first of all noting that this
is to the quarter end of
december and we're seeking leave
to have the financials for the next
quarter received in june just
running slightly behind because of some
of the processing and resourcing issues
great yep thanks jamie the floor is
yours
i'll take the report as being read but i
will highlight a few of the key points
um so yeah for the quarter the six
months ending
31st of december 2020 i'm currently in a
deficit of 1.9 million
but this is a better position than what
we'd forecast and also where we were
this time last year as well
some of the key points to note we've
received
three million of funding um for the
three waters
stimulus projects over the first half of
the year
capital expenditure is currently running
behind forecasts
however this normally picks up during
quarter three and quarter four
um the holding company is planning to
repay
icc um advance of 30 million which we
advance to them in 2016.
of which when icc receives it in quarter
four
we'll use it to pay off some our gfa
borrowings
so there'll be no net debt impact there
we have done some forecast changes um
increasing subseason grants by
4.8 million that's to cover um funds
we have received or will be receiving
from shovel ready
projects and also three waters stimulus
which i've mentioned earlier
um we're bringing forward the street
stop bank
project this is in line with the shovel
ready money we've
received but on the flip side we've also
reduced the core
um infrastructure renewal program to 70
of planned works just because of the
delays that are we're currently seeing
um we've also realigned a number of our
balance sheet
items to align with the opening balances
of the annual report
all these have been reflected within the
rtp forecasts as well which is out at
the moment
from a non-financial performance side we
currently
have 12 kpis which are sitting in the
non
achieve range this has gone up by two
from last quarter
the two that have moved into this range
now is
library visits are down and also the
landfill tonnage
which would supposed to be training to
be downwards is actually higher than
last year
now both of these have been slightly
affected by covert impacts
um so they may
not they may fail this year but next
year we should be
back on target for those
um from the treasury side um
so in the section we have expanded it
out to
show borings and cash and cash
investments
into separate crafts now um just this
highlights that
borrowings and cash investments are
higher than what we said in the ltp
last time however
with when you combine them both the net
debt balances
is lower than what we've seen in the ltp
so that's still a positive for the
council
and we are planning to use surplus funds
from the cash
um investments to pay off some of the
debt as well just because the interest
rates are
extremely low at the moment for term
deposits so
we'll get better benefit by paying off
our borrowings instead
um open to questions thanks jamie um
just before i throw it open
the reduction of the core infrastructure
capital renewal program of 70
i'm not sure whether i'll throw this to
you or erin but are we confident that
we'll hit that 70
target i'll throw that to erin
thank you chair i think the key piece
with
the the target of 70 is to be honest
that's usually
what we would achieve in a normal year
in terms of our renewals and and capital
delivery
um what we haven't been achieving is
obviously in that space of
major projects um so i wouldn't be ex i
would expect you know in a normal year
we'd achieve around that in the renewals
we're not at that space yet
in major projects and i don't expect
that we will get to that in
the couple of months we have left in
this financial year
the other part is that to be honest with
them
where we're at in terms of our financial
system transition
we don't have great visibility week to
week around where we are tracking in the
renewal
space either so that's making it a
little bit difficult for
us to keep i guess pushing that along in
the way that we
normally would at this point in the year
um
so i i wouldn't have confidence that we
would
hit that 70 this financial year okay
thank you any other questions or
comments from councillors
counselor clark through you chair um
couple of issues
um jamie in the um the report we've got
here
um we had a draft financial statement
are presented
to the risk and insurance committee and
there's some variation in the figures
so you might be able to help me with
that um
i guess the first one is that we've got
some total income
changes is that driven by extra money
that we've received
we've changed that report um most likely
accruals that we've identified
since the wrestling insurance meeting
yep um
the other issues i noticed on the
investment side of things that
when i tally up what we've got sitting
in banks
putting aside the other stuff we've got
about forty nine and a half million
dollars
and in those in the l t p documents that
were put out
that we were forecasting that we had
cash investments of about 40 million
so is that is that just an error or is
that are we just
sitting on a i guess a bit of a buffer
zone that might
allow us to use part of that
that remaining five nine and a half
million for some project work
um we're likely to use some of that
excess to pay off the borrowings
sure um but i will have to probably have
to come
wait and have a look at that so come
back to yeah so that leads on to another
question
if we and you suggested before that we
would use some of them potentially to
reduce our borrowings but then does that
open up our
percentage of borrowing that we can use
in the formula
for future work if we need it yes it
does
so that's that's a plus and isn't it
it's a plus um
the other issue is that when i look at
the reports it seems that we have an
ability in council and maybe this is my
ignorance
to change the year-to-date forecast
and this is not just in this report but
in previous reports as well
and i wonder what drives that because um
from my experiences
you set a forecast out for a for a
budget and then you measure yourself
on the actuals against that it seems to
me
that having the ability to change the
forecast pathway through the year
i can understand it for income but when
you're talking about expenditure
it allows you to sort of in some ways be
sort of superficially balancing the
books doesn't it
so when we report it then the year we're
always reporting against the annual plan
and the long-term plan okay the forecast
is there as a
guide of where we're looking to be
ending up at the end of the financial
year
you're comfortable with that counselor
yeah i'm not sure on the latter one but
maybe that's something i can explore
with michael at some later stage
yes thanks again any other questions or
comments on the financials
if not there are four recommendations to
be moved if someone would like to
put them forward move those chairs
counselor
seconded
there are no further questions or
comments
i'll put that motion all in favor
against
carried thanks jamie
which brings us to the activity report
welcome return of stephen michael thank
you very much
afternoon chair your worship counsellors
take the report as read
and darren michael and i are happy to
take any questions
and uh through the chair if i may um
michael david also like to provide an
update on some advice
uh after conversations with some
contractors
so should we start with that yeah
thank you chair so
over the last probably a few months
the ce clear myself and erin have been
conducting sessions with their
contractors and suppliers to
understand their
their position in the industry at the
moment and their capabilities from
delivery perspective
from our perspective through those
sessions
three key key themes came through
that there's the potential around
increasing price in relation to
[Music]
the works engaged in relation to
securing resource for themselves at the
moment is coming at a cost
that's one one thing that came through
the other thing was the capacity for
those suppliers and vendors to
deliver with
limited resources from perspective
across they are building their
capability
it's going to take some time the other
item that they brought up for us was
around raw materials
and the supply at the moment is
highlighted there is
demands on some some raw materials in
the industry
and they highlighted that that will
could or potentially become a constraint
as we
we go forward i thought it was prudent
to advise the council on this
in relation to our pending ltp
and just giving that insight into those
sessions that we've been conducting
thanks michael i guess some of those
supply
issues are not just uh ones for council
but
ones that are out there in the general
marketplace
uh councillor cricket welcome along
uh questions oh sorry yep welcome alex
councillor sopa thank you mr chair it's
not so much a question as
a comment from myself wearing two hats
um just to say that i was at the launch
of the covert 19
vaccination program yesterday at the
civic building
can i say from both those hats what a
suitable venue
that is for the process um and while i
i recognise it it's certainly useful to
have
up to 96 000 visits to the venue during
the time
and that's a benefit to the cargo city
council can i just say that the
dhb is very grateful at such an
appropriate venue
being available and i think it will
serve the purpose exceptionally well
the team who are doing vaccination seem
very
happy with the with the venue and the
support they've received
so thank you thank you uh it's it's good
that we've got
an accessible venue so centrally located
and
we certainly welcome these tenants for
the next
while which follows a year of a lack of
tenants
a question mr chair yes counselor
regarding the vaccination program
uh is there adequate car parking set
aside
outside the civic theater or
nearby uh thank you through the chair
um look we've worked with the dhb in
providing
car parking spaces primarily for the
staff
who are providing the vaccinations and
because their program's running from
somewhere at 7 30 in the morning through
until the end of the day
that's been the primary focus initially
for council staff
we have undertaken to continue to review
the car parking
from the public point of view and where
we'll be receiving feedback from the dhb
staff as to how that is progressing over
the next couple of weeks
um certainly the venue management team
are very
acutely aware of supporting the ongoing
access
but that's one of the benefits of the
civic theatre is there is
ample car parking nearby and mark
disability
car parks as well yeah thank you very
much
thank you any other questions or
comments on the activity report
counselor scout
i just do you cheer just um michael
steve
just on the points you made was there
any feedback from the
contractors and so on about the time
length of delays and bits and pieces
they perceived that to be an ongoing
issue for
some period of time or was there a level
of confidence that we may
see ourselves out of that at some point
in the near future
so through self-chair the the feedback
we
received in relation to timings was
quite interesting
in respect that they're basically saying
it's going to take
time to build the capacity and the
existing
workforce that we have in industry
they don't see this as a local or
regional
issue they see this as a national issue
and it's right it's right across
basically local government and
and the commercial side it's not just a
local government issue
i hope that answers that question just
on the materials in the sense of lack of
supply
is that is it possibly going to be
prolonged for some
period of time or perceived to be again
through yourself chair they
there was no defined
link to what type of raw material they
were talking about at the time
and it was a theme that came through so
they didn't
give us any specifics about what that
was
so falling out of that obviously that
that leads into our capital project and
what we're actually going to attempt to
achieve in the time frames we have
and the time frames we've got outlined
in our ltp so there's a word of warning
for us
around that is that what you're clearly
indicating
um i'm just providing feedback
counsellor from the
suppliers and vendors i'm not
pre-determining anything that they've
stated
thank you to be fair counsellor i think
that it also been signaled through the
um the process leading up to the
document putting it out that there's an
extensive work program
some of it is time-sensitive and some of
it can be
resource sensitive as as well i think we
saw
um some restrictions on timber uh that
was available for
the the building sector recently and you
know steel i guess could be just as as
vulnerable
um we don't know i know the trigger
wasn't loaded through youtube it was
just
getting information yep absolutely
councillor partner
um i mean it's it's it's a it's a common
theme right
right through the country uh supply of
both
either labor materials
but one thing that at least i hopefully
hasn't created the perfect storm
is interest rates are still reasonably
stable
and and hopefully will continue that way
where they are
because that would be if that if they
were to change in a negative way
then then you you would you would really
have to rethink things but as long as
that
as long as the affordability um was
is there to match our plans of our
financial plans
then the delivery time can be can be
accepted i think
uh but financially if the interest rates
were to increase dramatically then you
have to rethink everything yeah
fingers crossed we don't find ourselves
in that situation yet i still remember
back to the 20
plus in the 80s
well i remember my
great-great-great-grandparents talking
about it
councillor soper thank you mr chair um i
just wanted to
pay compliments to our library staff and
please pass that on
for the very good initiatives that are
in this report it's great to see that
the library is being used and
some pretty innovative ways to really be
that part of our community
and the other thing i just wanted to
acknowledge the invicable public art
gallery and
museum staff acting together in hey
wakatoya
and the exciting program they've got
developed there i think that's
that's really showing that they're
activating that
that facility so please pass that on too
see mr marriott sitting up in the back
so he'll certainly take that opportunity
as well
any other feedback or questions
counselors
if not thank you for what you've offered
so far uh would somebody like to move
the recommendation
and councillor lewis i'll put that all
in favor aye
against carrick stephen michael thank
you
brianna
so we've got the black multiple huey
tourism master plan
thank you chair kirakoto um yes so this
is an update on
the draft tourism master plan that's
been
produced by great south with support
from council
and with ewe as well so it lays out the
results
of the consultation that great staff has
undertaken with the community they have
good feedback
good engagement as well as a workshop
that the bluff community board held
and it outlines a suggested next steps
for finalization
so it's really presented here to you
councillor so that you've got an
opportunity to
raise any further points that you would
like considered as the
plan is finalized that finalization will
take the
um take the approach of
looking at implementation really so it
will be
around prioritization of projects from
timing
um yeah so it's an opportunity for
feedback
thanks rhiannon we've been engaged with
this process through several steps along
the way but here it is
and good to see there's been feedback
from quite a few other organizations as
well
so at rhiannon's invitation if there
were any other points or feedback you
wished
to provide now's a darn good time to do
it
councillor sopa thanks mr chair um ryan
just wondered
the last time we had the um councillor's
visit to
bluff the gun pit road development
looked fairly exciting and doc was to be
involved in that is
doc still fairly much on board with that
do you know
i wouldn't i don't have the latest
information on that but i can certainly
ask ask and find that out that'd be
great just to
just to know that they're still very
much on board with it it seemed like
a good part of the solution to some of
those sterling point
um over parking issues
thank you
councillor lush if you had a chance to
to go through that master plan
yeah look it's hard for me to come at
the stage and
fully comment on it um i guess the
question i have is
about the council's attitude towards
bluff
having read the plan and looking at
almost a paternalistic attitude towards
bluff from the invercargill city
and it seems as though the great
revival of bluff is going to be tourism
however i think we need to acknowledge
the
distinct
the very distinct function that bluff
has
it's not like tata it's not a commuter
suburb it's a separate
place from invercargill
and i wonder if invercargill's solution
towards bluff is to make it a tourist
destination
does in fact absolve them from some of
the responsibilities
to make bluff a functioning
and exciting and vital town
for me what is good as bluff is good for
tourism and i think since bluffs come
into the council
come into the area unlike a lot of towns
where the freezing works have closed
like
partial or whiter
the town has managed to
prosper despite very little engagement
from invercargill
and i just wonder if this focus on
tourism
is not slightly mislaid and the real
focus for the council should be on
the community of bluff itself what i
have noticed
is that as soon as we mentioned tourism
is that people buy up houses and bluff
and turn those into airbnbs
which means we've got a great rental
loss for bluff that people can't find
places to live
and these are people that work in the
fishing fleet in the port and i just
wonder if we've got the whole focus on
bluff back to front
i think what we i mean if we look at
bluff we look at
the town hall which got given to us
which is terrible
we look at the library and the
service center which is extremely run
down we look at the pool
which the community has to fund
themselves it seems the council does
nothing for bluff to make bluff seem to
be a great community
the great achievements we've got for
blah for the mirai and probably the
oyster festival which are community
projects
and i just think the council themselves
has got the wrong attitudes towards
bluff
and has kind of let it slip away the
playground needs to be fixed it's not
fit
for purpose and i just think that the
council
and future needs to look at bluff not as
a tourist destination we know the
signpost and we know the oyster and yada
yada
they need to look at it as a community
that is absolutely unique within new
zealand
and i think we'll see this with the
history that's coming out um and i think
i would like to certainly see part of
the museum focused there
um i certainly think that smag should
have pop-up shows there in some of those
buildings
and i just think we need to change the
way we look at it rather than okay the
freezing works is closed we're all of it
funny about bluff
let's get people to drive to the um sign
and give them a chance to
take the photo i think the council
should focus on making bluff
a vital and exciting community and i
think if that happens
then the tourism will follow i just
think for me the feeling is we've got
the horse before the cart
i'm sorry if that's a ramble but i just
feel that it's important that we say
that
particularly since it's been a long time
since we've had a counsellor
from bluff on this council
thanks councillor i guess in in feedback
the master plan is specifically about
tourism and that's just one aspect of
what happens
in bluff everything else falls into the
same category with everything else that
we deal with
in in council but within your comments
there's some some good feedback on
things that we can uh pick up on
but just to to reinforce this is
actually just specifically about tourism
it's really interesting to see how it's
um changed from from my observation of
taking a
young person down to ride down multiple
frequently
and that the tourists that are there
there are still plenty of camper vans
that are visiting it's just
um they're all being driven by uh by
kiwis now
um not that they don't strike a few
issues once they get to sterling point
and and some of the parking problems
there
it's been really interesting as we've
gone through the consultation process
not only with the bluff community board
but
uh also at the malai when we worked
through
what it what the priorities were that
the township was looking for
particularly with relation to tourism
what
their suggestions were but the the wider
uh bluff issue you've raised some good
points and they come up
like i say through the the annual plan
long-term plan process but thanks for
that feedback
counselor sopher thanks mr chair um i
just want to reassure
councillor lush i suppose um what i
found
in going to the bluff consultation
meetings
was very much that emphasis on the live
work play and the visit and invest were
the
fourth and fifth parts so even in
talking about the
the master plan as a tourism development
plan if you like
the live work play was very much at the
front of people's minds
and i think that that was definitely the
feedback the community was giving and
the feedback
i took as a counsellor that we're not
just talking about
bluff as a place to visit for a short
term
we're talking very much about the top
priority and the community board
all the meetings i've attended that's
been very much the top priority for the
community board i feel
that it's first a place that people live
work and play
it's a community and i'd like to
reassure
councillor lush that people around this
table
other councillors are very aware of that
and will certainly keep that in mind
thank you your worship then councillor
louis yes thank you mr chair
i've always been a fan of bluff and i
when i
first moved down here i said
this is the crowd in our tourism
industry
and they have had pretty good political
representation
um bruce pagan was the mayor there
in fluff it's the township
and he uh had quite a bit of influence
even though he only won by i think
about 100 votes or so but he
was dedicated
he was good at lobbying he was um
and houses were cheap i'm not trying to
have you on marcus but um houses were
cheap when i arrived here i brought a
three-bedroom house
for five thousand dollars and there were
a lot of that
a lot of people in that category
um but that didn't really fix the
problem i think
we've got to have an approach that's
pretty widespread and i know
the urge is to develop our panacea
uh aquaculture
but that can sort of
hit some really devastating problems in
a short time
but i think a broad-ranging approach is
probably the best one
thank you worship councillor lewis thank
you chief
i commend council lush for his comments
i also have an interest in bluff not
because i live there because i quite
like that many many years ago
almost hundred years ago i did some
locums down there
and it feels like a hundred years ago
anyway they now don't have a pharmacy
set
i can talk about any conflict um
but we must be also aware that the
some of the organizations from
invercargill including their wellbeing
fund
have actually financed recently quite a
lot of money for bluff
including money towards the information
kiosk which was discussed at length at
the bluff 2024 group
last night um i didn't really
participate in because i was actually
really interested what
well planned for the for the kiosk it's
still under the under the planning
system and i think our
our works sorry our parks are involved
with that also
the the murals that we put some money
towards eurich
were applied the money was applied for
by the bluff community
to help with the tourism so we have this
mixture i understand the housing things
because that was also discussed um
informally last night the number of
sections that are more difficult to buy
in bluff even just the ones with houses
or without houses on
um so there are two aspects the bluff
people themselves seem to want
an increase in tourism to help the
economy
the um one comment has been recently
about the
nowhere down there to get coffee on a
regular basis for tourists which puts
terrorists off
um i don't know if we need to get
involved for the commercial operations
and bluff themselves
but any help we can give them i guess
them and their sound separatism
but i think it is important we do give i
think
around about up to three hundred
thousand dollars a year towards the the
pool
in case anyone thinks we don't help with
the poor thank you mr g
thank you councillor any other comments
there's three recommendations if
somebody would like to move well
we've kind of taken care of the third
thank you councillor sober moved
seconded
your worship thank you i'll put that all
in favor
against kerry thank you for your
engagement counselors
uh local government new zealand uh the
annual general remits uh
really the report for mr thompson who's
unable to be with us this afternoon
highlights the time frame so if you're
thinking about things now is the
time to start thinking about suggesting
them
either at a at a workshop or to the
chairs or at the next
council meeting we can start a
discussion it's also a good time
to remind you that the conference itself
is coming up in blenheim
in early july and if anybody was
wishing to express an interest in going
if you could email claire um
by the end of the week that would be
useful so we can get an
idea of of numbers attending and how
that works and
with uh with budgeting i know councillor
craic
expressed an interest earlier this
afternoon but councillors if you're
interested in attending
lgnz if you could email clear by friday
that would be really useful
are there any comments on the reports
from mr thompson that will be received
thank you councillor leaving
the two recommendations both thank you
seconded counselor kit
i'll put that all in favor against
carried counsellors that brings us to
the end of
the public meeting thanks to those who
have joined us on the live stream that
will be finishing as we move
into public excluded which i will move
that we do for the reasons
as outlined in the agenda uh recognising
that
appropriate staff uh stay behind in this
case
uh mr marriott and with i'll second that
also with the addition of mr
jeff grant and lindsey mckenzie thank
you councillor sopa
put that all in favor against kerry
thank you for your attendance
you